[Applause]
[Music]
he may be the jeopardy clue that no one
answered right
who is mr magoo mr magoo
no but he's number 25 on our highest
paid athletes list
lefty aka philip alfred mickelson was
born in san diego california
in 1970. as early as three years old
phil was golfing alongside his father
and his grandfather
you could say golf was in his dna his
grandfather used to be a caddy back when
the pebble beach golf course first
opened
but it wasn't until phil senior turned a
right-handed club into a left-handed
club
that young phil got into the swing of
things showcasing his raw talent
in the sport phil always had a natural
passion for golf design
sketching golf holes in his notebook
when he was just 13.
he was a college junior when he won his
first pga tour in 1991.
to this day not one amateur has
accomplished that same feat
fresh off that win phil made his
professional debut in the 1992 u.s
open since then he's won 44 pga tour
events and five major championships
he's earned upwards of 92 million
dollars in prize money throughout the
years
second in the world behind tiger woods
he's also earned more than 750 million
dollars from sponsors throughout his
career
including callaway kpmg rolex
and amstel light tell a lefty what's
going on
and he's working his way up to a million
followers on instagram
where he posts pictures of himself
hitting the links videos that might get
him on the naughty list
and random hangs with larry david and
his childhood dreams came true
he designed his first course in 2001
and recently opened his latest nicholson
national golf club this summer
[Applause]
you